Zwingen uns äußere Umstände, demnächst
unseren Heimatplaneten zu verlassen?
Immer wieder gibt es Warnungen, dass der Klimawandel
die Erde schon bald unbewohnbar machen könnte.
Fest steht jedenfalls: Spätestens in fünf
Milliarden Jahren wird die Sonne das gesamte
Leben auf der Erde auslöschen.
Und so tüfteln Forschungsteams weltweit an
Ideen, den Menschen eine neue Heimat zu schaffen.
Statt den Mars zu besiedeln, könnte man doch
auch dem gesamten Planet Erde auch einen neuen
Platz im Universum organisieren.
Doch wie genau könnten wir die Erde verschieben
und so das Überleben der Menschheit sichern?!
Ein schottischer Raumfahrt-Experte hat dazu
eine Vision entwickelt… Clixoom Science
& Fiction - hier gibt es täglich spannende
Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert
die Glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Jetzt haben wir fast schon die Halbzeit erreicht.
Denn die Entstehung der Sonne liegt 4,6 Milliarden
Jahre zurück und noch rund 6 Milliarden Jahre
lang wird sie wohl wie ein normaler Stern
brennen.
Um 40 Prozent heller ist die Sonne nun schon
seit ihrer Entstehung geworden und klar ist:
Umso heller sie wird, umso wärmer wird auch
die Erde.
Schätzungen zufolge wird die Erde in 1,1
Milliarden Jahren so warm sein, dass auf ihr
nur noch Wüsten bestehen können.
Denn zu dieser Zeit wird die Sonne noch einmal
zehn Prozent heller sein als es derzeit der
Fall ist.
Der Wasserstoff im Kern der Sonne wird immer
weiter aufgebraucht und sorgt so dafür, dass
in etwa 3,5 Milliarden Jahren sogar die Meere
auf der Erde verdampfen werden.
In 6,3 Milliarden Jahren wird der Wasserstoff
komplett aufgebraucht sein und die Fusion
kommt zum Erliegen.
Der Überdruck im Kern sinkt, die Hülle wird
durch die Gravitation nach Innen gezogen.
Der Wasserstoff, der noch in der Hülle vorhanden
ist, erhitzt sich, sodass auch hier eine Kernfusion
zündet.
Es werden unvorstellbare Mengen an Energie
frei, die auch die äußeren Schichten erhitzen.
Die Sonne dehnt sich aus.
Innerhalb der darauf folgenden 1,3 Milliarden
wird sie auf das 100 bis 150-Fache ihrer jetzigen
Größe anwachsen.
Höchstwahrscheinlich wird die Sonne dabei
auch die Erde verschlingen.
Doch nicht nur dieses Szenario lässt Forschungsteams
weltweit Überlegungen anstellen, wie sich
das Überleben der Menschheit sichern lässt.
Auch die globale Klimakrise könnte dafür
sorgen, dass unser Heimatplanet in Zukunft
nicht mehr bewohnbar ist.
Der Raumfahrt-Experte Matteo Ceriotti von
der Universität Glasgow hat jetzt einen frei
verfügbaren Aufsatz im Netz (https://theconversation.com)
veröffentlicht, in dem er Überlegungen anstellt,
wie die Erde vielleicht doch noch zu retten
ist.
Demnach könnten wir einer drohenden Apokalypse
entgehen, indem wir die Erde in eine andere
Umlaufbahn bringen würden.
Diese müsste 50 Prozent weiter von der Sonne
entfernt sein als die des Mars’.
Das hätte den großen Vorteil, dass wir unseren
Heimatplanet gar nicht verlassen müssten
- anders als es beispielsweise bei einer Mars-Besiedlung
der Fall wäre.
Laut Matteo Ceriotti wäre diese Idee technisch
gesehen sogar umsetzbar.
Der Experte bringt dafür elektrische Triebwerke
ins Gespräch.
Er vergleicht dies mit dem Start einer Rakete,
die die Erde verlässt.
Durch die Triebkraft wird die Erde jedes Mal
minimal in die entgegengesetzte Richtung verschoben.
Vergleichbar mit dem Rückstoß einer Waffe.
Doch Ceriotti sagt auch, dass mehrere Milliarden
Raketen für diesen Plan gleichzeitig abgehen
müssten.
Erst durch den Start von 300 Milliarden “Falcon
Heavy” von SpaceX könnte die Erde tatsächlich
signifikant verschoben werden.
Der Planet würde so die Umlaufbahn des Mars’
erreichen.
Eine andere Idee wäre es, eine Art Triebwerk
an die Erdatmosphäre zu installieren.
Ein Ionen-Antrieb, also ein Strom geladener
Partikel, würde die Erde langsam aber sicher
in einen anderen Orbit bringen.
Dieses Mega-Triebwerk müsste Ceriotti zufolge
etwa 1.000 Kilometer über dem Meeresspiegel
angebracht und fest mit der Erde verbunden
werden, um die Schubkraft zu übertragen.
Doch auch hier gibt es Schwierigkeiten: Denn
um 87 Prozent der Erde zu bewegen, müssten
wir das Äquivalent von 13 Prozent der Erdmasse
in Ionen-Form ausstoßen.
Wie sollte das in der Praxis funktionieren?!
In seinem Aufsatz schreibt Ceriotti über
einen weiteren Ansatz, die Erde innerhalb
des Sonnensystems zu bewegen.
Und zwar durch eine Art Laser.
Die Energie für diesen fokussierten Lichtstrahl
könnten wir von der Sonne selbst bekommen.
Doch das würde viel zu lange dauern: Drei
Milliarden Jahre ununterbrochener Nutzung
wären den Berechnungen zufolge nötig, um
eine Änderung der Umlaufbahn zu erreichen.
Könnte vielleicht ein gigantisches Solarsegel
Abhilfe schaffen?
Ceriotti bezieht sich hier auf eine Studie
aus dem Jahr 2002, nachdem solch ein Sonnensegel
neben der Erde einen 19 Mal größeren Durchmesser
haben müsste als die Erde selbst.
Ein Umzug durch das Sonnensystem würde dann
eine Milliarde Jahre dauern.
Als eine weitere Möglichkeit, die Erde zu
verschieben, beschreibt der Experte den Vorgang
der Gravitations-Schleuder.
Schon seit den Voyager-Raumsonden wird diese
Technik der sogenannten Swing-by-Manöver
genutzt, damit Raumsonden quasi kostenlos
Energie tanken können.
Die Gravitationskraft der Planeten wird hier
genutzt, um Raumsonden zu beschleunigen oder
auch abzubremsen.
Denn wenn die Sonde als leichter Körper nah
an einem vergleichsweise schweren Himmelskörper
vorbeifliegt, bekommt sie quasi Energie von
ihm.
So kann nicht nur die Geschwindigkeit, sondern
auch die Flugrichtung geändert werden.
Um die Erde selbst zu bewegen, bräuchte es
laut Ceriotti etwas deutlich Größeres als
eine Raumsonde.
Kometen oder Asteroiden könnten verwendet
werden - auch, wenn dieser Vorgang dann mehrmals
wiederholt werden müsste, um die Erde in
einen anderen Orbit zu schieben.
Fingerspitzengefühl wäre gefragt, wenn ein
kleiner Körper aus seiner Umlaufbahn geschleudert
werden muss, um an der Erde vorbei schwingen
und ihr so einen großen Impuls verleiht.
Schätzungen zufolge wäre eine Million solcher
“Vorbeiflüge” von Asteroiden notwendig,
um die Erde von der Sonne wegzubewegen.
Auch dazu hatte es bereits 2001 eine Studie
gegeben.
Tatsächlich kommt Ceriotti zu dem Fazit,
dass der Einsatz von mehreren Asteroid-Schleudern
am realistischsten sei, die Erde an einen
sicheren Ort zu verschieben.
Solch eine Technik und auch der Einsatz eines
Solarsegels seien in der Zukunft noch am ehesten
in der Praxis umzusetzen.
Der Wissenschaftler hofft zudem darauf, dass
Licht in der nahen Zukunft weitere Möglichkeiten
für den einen möglichen Umzugs der Erde
bieten könnte.
Die Entwicklung superstarker Laser-Arrays
beispielsweise könnte der Knackpunkt sein,
um die Erde mit Hilfe von Licht zu verschieben.
Und den Planeten und das gesamte Leben auf
ihm vor der Zerstörung durch die Sonne zu
retten!
Klimawandel bedroht Küstengebiete: Kampf
oder Rückzug?!
- Ja, da beginnt jetzt schon die Umseidlung
noch auf unserem Planeten - Anklicken, anschauen
und Clixoom nature abonnieren.
Wenn ihr euch für Natur und Umwelt interessiert,
ist das ein Pflichtabo.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!